foreign
comes from William in New Mexico
are there new rules for buying used
versus new and Lease first financing in
this post-covet era my family has been
looking for a used car we can pay cash
for like we were taught in Financial
Peace University and we're finding used
cars only a few thousand dollars less
than new we also learned the insurance
companies are asking for additional
Bridge coverage since the used cars are
not as valuable as they're being sold
for ugh help please duh there you go
George okay so we're right down your
lane well there's a there's a lot going
on here that grinds my gears Ken going
boy not to have a car analogy I like
what you did there but this idea that
well used cars are only going for a few
thousand dollars less than new yeah if
you're looking at 38 000 used cars thank
you very much most people don't need to
be driving that uh based on the average
income people need to be looking for
fifteen thousand dollar cars and let me
tell you there's not five thousand new
cars but some people need to even be
looking at five to seven thousand dollar
cards store depending on their situation
and one of our favorite things to do is
go on I love it onto the internet and
what would you like to give me something
while you're teaching I'm going to pull
up a sample okay well you know a car
that we recommend here frequently is a
Honda so let's look up a Honda Civic all
right used let's just see in the initial
Edition all right you keep on teaching
so no there are no new rules for buying
used versus new and Lease first we Our
advice still stays the same stay away
from debt at all costs and save up and
pay cash for a reliable used car no we
don't mean take a briefcase full of
dollar bills to the dealership that's
not going to work but you can take a
money order or cashiers cashier's check
and go and do that now a lot of
dealerships make their money through
financing the margin on cars can be as
low as six percent the margin on
financing can be as high as 60 percent
and so when you walk in there and you
tell them hey I'd like to pay cash a lot
of the times they're gonna sometimes
they'll say we're not gonna sell it to
you at that price because they don't
make enough money on the deal they'll
wait for the next guy to walk in who's
ready to finance and so you've got to
know exactly what you're walking into
and this means doing all your research
ahead of time online knowing the value
of the car you're going to buy and you
can tell them you can wait till the end
and say what's the out the door price
that's what you're looking for is the
out the door price because that includes
all of the fees and when you look at
those fees make sure you don't pay
anything more than sales tax and a small
doc fee anything else is highway robbery
they go oh that's a mandatory warrant no
I'm not paying that and watch what
happens when you walk out the door
they'll be chasing you within three
minutes because they see a guy with a
check in hand ready to buy all right so
what do you got for me Ken all right
thank you George this is a my favorite
things to do so Ken here's the the
people objection is Ken there's no cars
under fifteen thousand dollars I gotta
go buy a 38 000 used car and I would say
that is not true and I've got the
results right here George I just got a
quick search uh using AutoTrader in the
Franklin Tennessee area okay all right
and I'm gonna give you some options here
okay first we've got a used 2008 Honda
Civic EX uh 129 000 miles which for a
Honda is barely getting started the car
hasn't even woken up yet the cars
thank you very much seven thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars wow okay uh
by the way it's a nice little blue paint
job it looks fine all right let's go up
a little bit all right uh we've got a uh
what about in the 10 000 range Ken what
can we get there's no need to shout
George sorry I'm getting excited uh here
we go we have a used 2008 Honda Civic
it's an EXL that's top of the line it's
an e see you know EXL I owned one you
did yeah 145 000 miles again for a Honda
not a big deal nine thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars so that's
just below the uh the threshold is it
gonna impress anyone no no we'll get you
from A to B with very little repairs and
maintenance costs yes yeah yeah oh sorry
yeah yeah yeah so they get that's just
one example uh I get very excited about
this because I'm in the market right now
for a teenager and I'm looking at this
stuff all the time by the way I should
point out Facebook Marketplace great
place to find good deals and you can
negotiate over there yes now you're
dealing with a private seller and and uh
you show up with cash
Dave Ramsey taught me that many years
ago I mean literally show up and go this
is what I'm paying right now and you
count it out lay it on the hood of the
car and do it somewhere public by the
way if you're gonna do that yeah don't
put yourself in a precarious situation
bring it bring a friend with you by the
way grocery store parking lots great
place to do that Banks uh police you
know you can go to all these places
that's great meet me at the police
station police station is one of the
deals happen my friend oh wow you really
are scared young you were really scared
well anyways I don't know what it's like
in New Mexico I can't imagine it's much
much different it's not so yes if you
want to buy an insane used car yeah it
might be a few thousand lessons oh look
at this George I Gotta Throw one more in
here use 2015 Honda Civic 106 000 miles
they're asking 11-9 there you go so
don't tell me it can't be done so it can
be done absolutely and we don't tell
people uh to go out and buy a new car
until they have a net worth of a million
dollars or more and that's for one
simple reason it's just too much of your
world to spend that kind of money on a
depreciating asset yeah so there you go
William hope that helps